a little bit about myself
I'm Sagitta whatever your labs good yeah
thanks
so um my role is a data scientist role
mostly self-taught prior to this I was
doing search and natural language
processing and over the last few years
have been doing some machine learning
and deep learning as well I got
interested in nerds about some time last
fall when I was doing some work in
relation with search and knowledge graph
development so I wanted to build some
custom named entities and this seemed to
be a nice thing to do a disclaimer I am
NOT neither the author nor were the
original maintainer of nerds this was
built by buying colleague panagiotis
from my Amsterdam office there's a bunch
of contributors and my name isn't there
either they're all from the Amsterdam
office and from the same group this was
open source like a year and a half ago
and one thing I would like to say though
I'm not just a happy user I picked it up
and made some changes to it and they're
all knife work and I think my changes
are actually you know I'm hoping to fold
them in around January February next
year and you'll find that I have more
functionality in my fork than the
original one so that's something I
wanted to just mention so the agenda
here is broken it up into five little
sections so let's go okay so why would
you even care about any or I guess some
of you might actually care because you
do it
it's body feed a job but for the rest of
you it's basically a foundational task
for any NLP pipeline just like part of
speech tagging phrase chunking you know
even sentence splitting and so on right
there are good name netting recognizers
available you know
trained entity recognizers that are able
to detect standard named entities like
people places things or organizations
and stuff but really I am looking for
custom ners right things that I can
build myself
any other also so the out named entities
the availability of name entity is also
useful for downstream tasks like maybe
topic modeling core efference resolution
and so forth for myself I found any is
useful in information retrieval to chunk
your queries into meaningful pieces and
also to understand query intent I'll not
go into depth I actually built a system
totally based on a needs and which
understood query you know he is very
intent the other thing that you actually
need to do is if you are doing knowledge
graph constructions so typically a
knowledge graph is a bunch of triples
like subject predicate an object and the
subject and object are basically
entities so again you need entities to
you know get the subject and object
before you can do relation extraction so
that's another you know kind of thing
and if you combine the two you get the
holy grail of search concept search a
semantic search right so so these are
probably the reasons why you would care
right I'm going to go through a you know
kind of a whirlwind tour of NER
techniques for those of you who are not
you know who are not doing any are for a
living as I am doing right now for well
typically any our techniques are you
know they go from the traditional to the
neural traditional are like rules or
regular expressions rules could be
things like finding names proper nouns
and you say ok you know the rule is that
those words must begin with a capital
letter
regular expressions could be things like
looking for dates and times different
kinds of formats gazetteers are
basically just dictionaries of terms and
the idea is that you have this
dictionary and your text you find
instances of these terms in your text
right and it's kind of old school but
don't knock it it's very very useful
right for statistical for those of you
who come from the search side you are
looking for basically things like you're
looking for sequences of words who the
empirical probabilities are higher than
if you multiplied the probabilities of
the individual words together right so
if you
multiply the probabilities it means
they're independent right so that that's
why you're saying that the probability
of the three things together you know
occurring together is very low but if
the empirical probability is higher then
that's an entity it's not a named entity
but it's some entity of interest right
there's also sequence models of which
the most popular one is conditional
random fields which we will talk about
slightly later on the neural side of
things there is the bi-directional STM
which is the basic building block of any
R and as well as you know a lot of other
things that even part of speech tagging
for instance but most real neural models
for any R also include a CRF head CRF is
the conditional random fields and of
course since the beginning of this year
there's has been a bunch of transformer
based models so the ones here in orange
are the ones that nerd supports out of
the box so we'll talk to talk about that
later a little bit more one other thing
I wanted to bring up again for those of
you I apologize to those of you who are
already into any other and know all
these things is the standard data format
that we use it's called vio tagging vio
stands for begin in or out so if you
look at the example up there so you find
that there are the whatever tagger that
is the hypothetical dagger has actually
found two entities in there
Barack Obama and in other states right
so in the BIU tagging you would
basically tag Barack Obama Obama as
beginning of person and Obama is in
person and similarly with United and
States and every other token is termed
as out so it's not in the NER sequence
there is a variant called be ILO you
wear bo u bi n over the same you stands
for unit for single tokens and L stands
for last so in this case Barack Obama
would be Barack be poor and Obama would
be L per rights in the Balu system the
other thing I wanted to point out is the
Kwan a little format it's based on the
shared tasks where you basically
represent your data the tag data is
basically a two column vertical format
right so the first column is the token
the second column is the tag and it's
tab separated and at the end of each
sentence you have a MP line to mark the
end of a sentence so reason I bring this
up is because that is the standard
format I'm going to have nerds use right
sir
for gazetteers that's the first one we
are talked about you know the
traditional setup usually most
gazetteers in the market today
use the hakura SiC algorithm the ho
classic algorithm was first published in
1975 still being used essentially all it
is it you take your dictionary and you
create the data structure like that
right and then you essentially you
stream your content one pass single pass
against the this data structure and as
you stream it will you know think of it
as hitting the O 0 node and it will try
to find tokens that it can navigate to
and at the end of so if you look at that
the barackobama it just navigates down
to barack and obama and then at the end
of it it cannot navigate any further so
it comes back here it reports that I
found a power and it comes back here
right and back to the 0 node so the nice
thing about this it's like a single pass
algorithm you don't have you know
regardless of the size of a dictionary
you only do a single pass against the
data right the second one is conditional
random fields essentially the the
easiest way to think of conditional
random fields is it's a sequence version
of logistic regression right so if you
have these tokens you can find features
for each of these tokens and you can
independently predict the tag for each
of the tokens right in normal register
progression now consider that you can
also look at the previous label the next
label the entire sentence you know any
other token entire sentence and so
essentially the entire sequence is
available to you right and you can
basically create a labeling over you
know this L right of tags over the
entire sentence the best level and how
you do it is basically you create these
features right the feature is the
function of the sentence the current
position previous tag next tag and you
weight them and you basically sum them
up for each token and then put the
entire sentence you sum up this set of
you know token scores and then you learn
the weights here because you did a set
of weighted features for each token and
you learned these weights using gradient
descent right so that's typically the
approach and this is actually for those
of you who have done hmm have struggled
with it and you know concluded that CRF
must be even more tough it's not true
that was me I used to think that but
this is like totally you know xenakis
neural models the simplest thing is
vilest um it's basically two recurrent
neural networks pointing at it you know
going to opposite direction one reading
front to back and the other reading back
to front and of course in neural
networks it's not just words going in
you essentially you create embedding so
do these right so it's a vector and then
on the other side it's actually a vector
of probabilities of which the
probability of beeper is the highest
right so that's how you so it's kind of
an abstraction here oh the nice thing
about it is unlike CRF where you
actually have to do manual feature
engineering there there is no manual
featuring engineering here you just
trade compute and data for the extra
manual work right again like I mentioned
real world any earth have this CRF layer
on the head right this is the CRF head
on top and essentially everything is the
same except for this additional CRF a
and the CRF that the the features that
the CRF consumes is basically the hidden
states that come out of each of these
neural networks right the ordinance that
there
and oh the other thing that I read here
that pre-trained embedding so
essentially you can either learn the
embeddings from scratch right so you
start with random vectors and as you
train it basically figures out their
bearings or you could pre populate for
each word you could look up something
like word to wake and find say you know
what is the embedding for Barak right
and you put it in there and then over
time it modifies that so that's what
this means pre-trained embeddings
observed are observed to improve the
performance so something to keep in mind
if you're actually building something
that is so the next step from the word
embedding so we talked about this right
so this is basically consuming words and
creating M bearings and you know it's
basically creating that breaking the
tags right so the next step here was
basically to expose the signal in the
characters itself why because there
might be some characters if you're
looking up in bearings words then there
might be some words which may not be in
your embedding dictionary right so and
the other thing is that there is signal
in the word structure itself so if you
have words which end with ly for
instance or even words that end with pre
or saw right so those mean something
right peep on right postpone that's our
thing
so it explores the signal so essentially
what it does it takes a word right like
United decomposes it into a sequence of
characters and then uses a neural
network to basically extract a vector
out of this right and the word vector
that you got from this one and the
character vector did you got from this
one are then concatenated and then sent
to the by C Wireless gems your effect
right so it's like an additional thing
that so again all the weights are
learned end to end and this is and so in
in nerds you will find the neural
network model it can optionally take the
character of this gem the other thing
you can think of is that this is mainly
useful for things like what two vacant
love the older type of M bearings if you
think of
things like sub words in weddings like
fast text it that actually contains a
lot of the information that this guy is
going to talk about because it contains
about a Marines right again something to
keep in mind so so the next step is to
basically replace the word embedding the
static word embeddings that you got with
contextual word n bearings right so
there is a model in nerds which uses
Elmo
so essentially you pass the entire
sentence to Elmo and Elmo will give you
back a sequence of words so if you think
of a word like Bank for instance right
so Bank could be a river bank bank could
be a place where you put money in case
of glove and what to Vic the embedding
return is exactly the same right however
depending on the sense in in which you
use the word Bank the embedding scene
out of Elmo or any other contextual
embedding system would be different
right so so this is again another little
improvement to go forward with and
finally of course we have board and and
it's variants definitely so there are
two ways to use board
one way is basically to replace this
component with a word component right so
that's the easiest simple way the other
way to think about it is that birth
itself is a language model that has been
trained with large amounts of text and
it has learned how to learn the
structure of sentences it has learned
how to you know figure out what sentence
or what word is what sense and so forth
right so if you then fine tune this this
language model the word language model
with your own data which is basically
words and tokens and tags right you
could come up with a model that is
basically an Indian tree extraction tool
right this is not their innards yet but
I'm working on it and it's coming soon
like you know so it's maybe January or
so
yeah
I know so that was that was this one
right so if you extract if you just
replace this Elmo component with the
bird component it would basically just
extract bird pre-trained bird vectors
right into a CRF yes yes on the bird
side all this is built-in
so essentially you are saying that here
is my language model there is no CRF
it's like a sequence to sequence model
right except that you know it's not like
context it's everything comes in to you
know it's like parallel right it's end
to end kind of model yeah my question
was what's gonna be the algorithm that
you'll be feeling this data in okay so
essentially what I'm doing here is that
I'm fine tuning this model right
this model is already a language model
it knows how to you know work with
English let's say it's English I now
find unit to take in tokens and return
these tags so slightly different tasks
but it's still leveraging the structure
of the sentence right so that's so I
haven't done this yet you know but this
is in the works
you know this is come most likely in
January February timeframe it should be
R here is some more information I like
this this high-level overview it's a
series of blog posts the rest of it is
basically survey papers slightly old but
it has a lot of coverage so you know
just is there and I will share the
slides so you don't have to actually
take pictures if you let me know which
don't have to so back to nerds right
what the architecture is so according to
nerds own readme dot MD file it's a
framework that produces easy to use any
are capable HD data scientists right and
how it does that it it basically wraps
popular third-party any are models it
doesn't have to you could write your own
models and : through nerds and again so
new third-party tools can be either you
know your own or third-party and your
tools can be added and I think of it
less as a data science thing then more
and more of a software engineering thing
right so it basically makes simplifies
data science tasks for people who are
doing any are right and basically I am
here because you know if you guys
downloaded use it like it give us starts
that way you know we get support and it
is easier for us to basically tell
management that we should put more
effort into it right so that's one bug
reports contributions and ideas also
right totally so how does it do this
right essentially does it a bit like
government does it right or the EU for
instance that caters to the lowest
common denominator so essentially we
have this common data format right each
of these guys they have their own
different data format that they consume
and they return right and here we had
this common data format and using nerds
we have converters that are able to
consume this and you know passing the
data to this guy in one way this guy in
another way and this guy in another way
and so forth right
and again outputs from these are again
converted back to this format and sent
out so you have a common API that talks
you know that as a data scientist you
can talk to and internally it works on
these different models benefits it's a
consistent API so all models are
subclass is the venire model so you have
four things here fit is for training
predict is for predicting save is to
save your model to disk lorries to
retrieve it so it's very scikit-learn
like although other tell you later is
not exactly scikit-learn you know
compatible so however one big as a data
scientist one big advantage you will get
is that you have to do your data
preparation only once right and can
reuse it across different models we have
provided some reusable training in
evaluation code which I am trying to get
rid of
and revert more to scikit-learn and use
theirs there is a familiar scikit-learn
like api as you can see fit predict and
whatnot and because all of them have the
same api the duck typing you know idea
of Python which walks like a duck you
know it is a duck right it allows us to
build ensembles out of these things
right so you can actually call them
using the same thing and the last one is
probably something that you know I find
very dear to my heart is that you know
if you are actually having domain
experts build your in your data for you
they are going to constantly come back
and say how much do you need right and
honestly you don't know right in most
cases it depends on how difficult it is
and so forth and so this gives you a
nice idea you say you know you say okay
give me like a thousand sentences right
and then you run it and you see what you
get and then if it's not good enough you
either go back and say you're you know
tagging is not right or you say give me
more data right so this actually helps
you you know you can basically baseline
your data really fast okay so so the
thing is that you know we talked about
our data common data format and that's a
really good idea but I started looking
at it and I wasn't able to make this guy
write the violaceum one run and the
reason for it is because the old code
was written against an older version and
the Onaga virus TM thing there's a
third-party tool and they had changed
their API in the meantime and so when I
went in I still could not make it run it
would give me like at the end of five
epochs it will give me some time stamp
error and I worked on it I tried to fix
it but I couldn't so ultimately in
frustration I went back and you know did
it against the third party tool you know
wrote my code against the third party
code itself taking any route knots out
in the process and it worked so then I
started looking at it and I realize that
you know so this was the native format
that this guy consumed right and then I
saw that this one too consumed the exact
same native format so two out of four
had the same simpler native format right
so I basically wrote and these
kind of similar they took like span
oriented things instead of a list of
tokens and list of tags they took a list
of spends as the the labels and so I
figured that it's fairly easy to write
converters for the ones that do not
conform to this standard and go forward
with that so that's how I came up with
this
I think it's simpler but you know and so
you know so this is my new the fourth
version basically uses the simpler data
format and as a result of that I also
got a new model for free write this one
so while while you know between the time
that it was open sourced and the time I
started looking at it the Anangu project
basically created a new this guy the new
Elmo based NER thing and I basically
could hook it up it was like you know
five minute job to so I'm going to just
go through the Nords usage pattern and
for that I took a data from this bio NLP
2004 bio entity recognition task it has
four five different kinds of entities
and it's all it's all tagged in bio
format and in coronal format so I had
about five hundred thousand training
examples and about hundred thousand test
examples and the entity distribution as
you can see was for DNA RNA cell line
cell type in protein and as you can see
it's actually not very balanced it's
quite unbalanced right although that
does not actually affect you for the
good any ours but you see it read so if
you look at the calling sequence the
calling pattern it's actually quite
simple right so essentially you
instantiate it right instantiate your in
your model you train it and then you can
optionally save it and retrieve it which
I did just to test the whole thing and
then you can take your train model and
generate predictions on it right so it's
like three lines and then you can
generate your classification report
these are some you know like kind of
adapter functions that I have but this
classification report comes from secular
right so and you can see that you know
it looks exactly the same and so and you
can see is like about six point six five
from a dictionary in here so it's not
that bad and incidentally dictionary in
ears are usually the first line of
defense because you know most companies
have ontologies and dictionaries about
their domain and you know that's a very
useful baseline even though it's like
1975 technology so the thing I did here
the improvement that I did was you know
this was this had a different pipeline
in the old nerd system I basically
converted it to the fit you know fit to
train predict to predict right setup and
also made it handle multiple entity
classes for some reason that handled
only single class there's no reason the
automated the Hawker AIESEC automaton
cannot handle more than one class at a
time so I just made the change the
second one was again this was the CRF
'near okay so the improvement here is
that they had a dependence here in NL TK
and now you know and I was using Spacey
anyway so I just took out an LT case so
I don't have the other big improvement
here was that the feature you know the
feature ization of your tokens was kind
of transparent it was hidden under the
NER so I still have that as my default
but if you want to add more features you
can do so in this new system right so
you can actually pass in features as
well but if you look at the way in which
you call it you will and if you remember
what the dictionary NER had is identical
right there is no difference except the
only difference here is that you call a
different model
everything else is same when it gives
you a slightly better number 7/7
spacey again you know this Spacey NER is
actually based on Spacey and it's not a
by Ellis TMC or if it's the neural model
but it's actually a state-of-the-art
very close to state-of-the-art according
to the documentation so again you know
the calling sequence is identical very
boring now and the only difference I did
was I use mini batches
this is easier to work with follower
datasets it's kind of it was an
oversight I'm guessing where the
original code so I just fixed that this
gives you about 78% right and finally we
have the CRF in here this is again the
only thing I did here was make it work
because it didn't work calling sequence
is the same and you get like 78% the
ELMO NER is it needs an additional glove
or some kind of static word emitting
okay and some kind of static word
embedding and so that's why I've had
this exist check otherwise again the
calling sequence is the same and this
was the one I got for free right and
this one gives me about 80% f1 and here
is an ensemble example the only thing
here is that I already pre trained those
things so I loaded them in and then I
call it here in the fit in sorry
so in the fit I basically pass in the
estimators I want one sample
I could also so fit is basically for
training right oops
so fit is basically for training but I
already have pre trained so I say is pre
train true and I don't pass any of the
the parameters for fit in here so these
are empty parameters here and again you
do predict here just like you do
normally and you get this kind of
results so I wanted to kind of show you
a comparison across the different models
that we have if you notice 0.65 I'm
getting f1 scores I have done nothing I
have written three lines of code per
model right I'm getting f1 scores from
point six five two point eight which are
pretty good as a baseline I have not
done any hyper parameter tuning right so
this can give you a very good baseline
to start your work with and even across
entity types if you notice this is from
the ELMO model and f1 scores range from
point six one and point eight one right
so the idea is that you can you know
leverage existing function ID and create
your custom menus really really fast
right
future work I have a bit so like I
mentioned the current API is
superficially cycled on like so it has
issues with serialization when it comes
to parallelizing using geo blip parallel
so essentially it means that I cannot
train them in parallel right because it
will not serialize correctly it's not a
big deal because most of the time you
would actually train it earlier and then
just use it for prediction effort on
something also if I can make it
scikit-learn compatible I can basically
just use I can eliminate my on some of
them in ER and use the scikit-learn
voting classifier instead right and also
I can leverage the randomized search and
the grid search Mehta estimators from
scikit-learn so those are that's ones
big structural change I want to make in
the future I also want to add flare and
bird based NER I mentioned the coming
soon
that's the word based NER is the coming
soon and there is the other one which is
brat brat is a manual you know used by
domain experts to hand annotate
documents and that creates an XML output
so essentially I want to you know be
able to directly adapt and copy you know
get it into my own format and use my
models so these are my annotation that's
the future work I have and this is all I
had so that QR code you can actually you
can actually if you want to go to the
github page you can go type this in or
you could point your camera at this QR
code and that will take you there in the
readme there is a link to the slides so
you know so that's that's pretty much
all I have I'm open to questions if you
cannot handle questions within the time
frame we can you can either catch me
outside or you can email me and yeah so
thank you
[Applause]
it actually the it ended up getting the
best course for so in my case I did the
ensemble out of the four things I have
not the alma one because Elmo takes a
lot of time so this course I got were
actually the best in each category
almost right so it didn't boost it in
the sense that you know okay
overall it boosted it but it didn't
boost it on the individual you know I
got like 78 f1 score overall which was
the same as what I got with spacey and
the vilest Ian do you consider 80
percent f1 as yeah f1 or yeah did the
state of the art these days pretty close
to it and yeah I guess I mean I I would
want to go higher though before it is
usable what's the highest you've ever
gotten with any years I've got about
eighty seven ish but I would really like
to go to about ninety eight ninety plus
two questions first is do you have a
reference for that protein paper you
show the results this is not a paper
this is I basically took it from here I
can I don't have a I might have it but I
don't have it on me here okay
where is this here so this is the buy 1
lb 2004 tusk I might have it give me a
second
it might I might have it the second
question is I've just asked when you're
looking for and Elmo is a character base
in bedding right Elmo is not character
based I think it's contextual but in the
training it's like it broken into
character base it's broken into sub
words so it has its tokenizer but if you
say so in my example like 44th right it
will actually break it up into 44 and th
right so that that part yes it breaks it
up into sub words but not consistently
like
fast textures fast X breaks it up
regardless of inflection it breaks it up
into three character trigrams and you
know uses that so each word is basically
the sum of the embeddings for the three
character diagrams thank you but this
one is more inflection based so it's the
Google's tokenizer so if you go to the
website the github and you go under
examples and bio NLP it has the link to
that right sorry good I guess it's a
volume and level of effort of annotating
for your training set I mean you see you
have some training sets already done but
if I was starting from scratch what's
sort of the level of effort and amount
of documents I mean it depends a lot I'm
sure but yeah usually typically like I
mentioned here I you know this is my
ballpark kind of thing I usually say
give me like a thousand sentences and
it's there and it could go up to like
five thousand six thousand sentences you
think how much effort like if you had to
do that now for a new entity how would
you go about doing it how long would it
take
so typically we you know we have like
teams of three or four domain experts at
a time and they would you know you give
them about week week and a half is about
per per batch of questions okay yeah
let's thanks it
[Music]